So here, are the two crucial ingredients.
I have many features available to me, but I hypothesize that there's
a smaller number of features that are actually driving the patterns in the data.
And then, what I do is I take that knowledge and I try making a composite
feature that more directly probes the underlying phenomenon.
These composite features are what we'll be talking about in this lesson.
They're called principle components.
And it's an extremely powerful algorithm.
In this lesson,
we'll mostly talk about it in the context of dimensionality reduction,
how you can use principle component analysis.
Or PCA, to bring down the dimensionality of your features to
turn a whole bunch of features into just a few.
It's also a very powerful standalone method in its own right for
unsupervised learning, and I'll give you some of my favorite examples of
that in the latter half of this lesson.
It's going to be really cool.
So, here's an example of what PCA is,
transforming from square footage plus number of rooms into a single
variable that roughly tracks the size of the house.
>> So, let's suppose this is my training data,
I have the square footage on the x axis and the number of rooms on the y axis.
Now, what I'm going to do is I'm going to draw in the principle component.
It will look something like this.
I know this looks like a regression at this point, but it's not, and here's why.
With the regression, what you're trying to do is you're trying to
predict an output variable with respect to the value of an input variable.
Here, we're not really trying to predict anything.
We're trying to come up with a direction in the data that we can project our
data onto while losing a minimal amount of information.
So, here's what that means.
Once I've found my principal component, once I have the direction of this,
of this vector, of this line, and just go with me for now, that it exists.
We'll come back to how we find it in a little bit.
Then, what I'm going to do is I'm going to take all of my data points.
And, I'm going to go through a process that's called projection.
And, what a projection means, it's a little bit of a physical term almost.
Imagine that I have a light and the light is sort of
shining down perpendicular to the surface of this principle component.
Then, you can imagine that all of the data points are going to be
sort of casting shadows down onto like a piece of paper if I put it there.
Now, my principle component looks like this.
So I start out with two dimensional data.
But, once I've projected it down onto the principle component,
it's in one dimension and it's going to look something like this.
Now, instead of being the blue circles, my data is going to be the black xs.
I've turned it into a one dimensional distribution.
I've taken the feature that I've made in this diagram and sort of turned it so
that it's lying flat.
What's it going to look like?